mais maintenant tu dis quoi ok c'est bon
la session ça marche jon morse et
squeeze aux jeunes d'en valider et jay z
pour les défis de squeeze épisode mais
je ne pourrais pas dire mais le procédé
dit de claudie voilà exact c'est tout ce
qu'on sait et on se retrouve pour un
défi de squeeze fantin boulesque
titanesque exactement mais diaby vidal
est alors alors aujourd'hui donc écouter
on n'a pas pu relire tous les
commentaires toutes les vidéos mais en
fait on fait avec ça sur mes abonnés
encore merci tout le monde on fait le
retour des défis de squeeze donc un par
mois
il y en aura donc on compte sur vous
pour lâcher un maximum d'idées sur ces
vidéos à des idées originales des trucs
faisable pas des trucs et écopé lundi
avant de faire ça les regarde et la
précédente vidéo pour voir si c'est
quelque chose qui a pas et cela a fait
cela le système vous connaissez pas le
concept allait voir et ben moi je fais
une brève explication du court ça oui
massive asile qu'en fait c'est à chaque
mort dans call of duty modern warfare 2
donc comme vous voyez à l'écran et ben
en fait on se tape ou enfin vous allez
voir les différentes vidéos on mange
quelque chose ou et c est donc bon on a
dû rapidement qu'on mange à chaque mort
9 points même source hu a eu lieu à un
truc dégueulasse un tueur les lieux
exacts eu rouge
voilà en fait on en a déjà fait pas mal
aidé fidesz convient donc ça date de
quand j'avais vingt mille abonnés donc
je sais que ceux qui ne suivaient à
cette époque veulent vraiment le retour
c'est pour ça que l'on en fait on fait
le retour des défis de squeeze mais bon
voilà écouter alors aujourd'hui ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va prendre une
cuillère de cannes est là à chaque mort
dont crois que ça s'appelle le sinaman
challenge donc qu'est ce que c'est que
le cinéma challenge a fait c'est ça
donc voilà donc c'est un truc un peu à
voilà c'est un peu c'est un peu fou
c'est un peu un peu calqué sa te nique
bien la gorge puis ça peut être très
dangereux donc on va pas trop faire les
malins non plus et voilà on fait
attention chez vous ne reproduisez passé
comme dans l'esprit comme dans les cités
par les professionnels
ouais mais tu veut sérieusement en fait
là chaque mois on va prendre une petite
cuillère on n'a pas cherché trop parce
que généralement le scénovision c'est un
mec qui prend eau depuis hier est donc
là si on prend de turin chaque mois ça
va pas le faire donc on va prendre une
petite une petite bière pas trop d'oser
quoi les stars de l'histoire l'histoire
de vraiment pas mourir sur en vidéo quoi
ce sera pareil j'espère au moins que la
vidéo sera un peu de mon ami web en
meurt en fait vous aurez jamais cette
vidéo claude lorsque je vous dis là ça
sert à rien donc
donc voilà donc en fait il faut compris
pour être encore en vie alors attendez
donc on est en tdm à chaque mois enfin
dans tout les frais de ce reportage
bon là la première mort on en prendra
mais toutes les deux morts où toutes les
trois autres membres n'a jamais goûté
encore on n'a jamais fait autant fait
antoine abus sexuels rentes ai tout à
l'heure à elle ça pue et la cannelle
déjà web bien qu'en soir aux usa
elle se dit que j'ai la prise par l'asie
demeure là et si je meurs je te tue
mexique
ok tu es prêt bientôt avec sa cible à
côté on a une bassine alors vas-y
attends je vais faire un petit round est
vrai
[Musique]
oh [ __ ] c'est vrai que ça prend
beaucoup la salive à 5 ans h coca est ok
tu en as tu es mort sinon ces bombes
arrivent à 0 farid paya présidente à
doazit un [ __ ] c'est ignoble à l'effet
des plus grosses et des plus loin c'est
un oeil sur la tarte aux pommes ça se
sont pas autant quoi ah ouais à la c'est
vrai que ça son essai s'est formé ccc
ccc et puis c c et puis c'est normal
c'est une équipe qu'on garde mais c'est
quand même très difficile pour une épice
c'est ça s'est passé pour les nuls ou
ram c'est super que du coup à la cepal
les pistes de [ __ ] non mes mecs
tarière mille maisons plus voudrais
m'élever la safer montagne non elle
était prêt c'est parti j'ai plus de
saïdia et mon gars je t'avoue que ça se
bichonne route du plaisir non non j'ai
cru que ces masses ligue 1 alors va dire
refait encore récupère la balle hors jeu
vidéo sur mathieu ou tiger woods aura de
nouveau sur ta cagoule en plein défi
emploi depuis punta cagoule wayne rooney
à gauche un mec sur toi va se passer
bien piqué toujours très passionnant
dans l'édifice à l'asie comme logo
antoine je chante la banlieue sale el
sol est pour moi celle c'est mon gars
alors sinon on voulait parler d'un sujet
je ne sais plus lequel j'aimerais
refaire utile aux la doublette au la
doublette la barre qui font aussi du
mode super bien plus affecté 15 mois par
les méga décharge l'iphone est descendu
dans mon prénom est ce qu'elle est
descendue dans l'arrière garde fous ta
cagoule est restée forte dans l'île
les prix des biens mundau il n'a pas
compris ce qui l'aiderait choix je la
connais dans le poumon à wemmel c'est
que c'est ce qu'ils s'excusent et non
parce qu'on a vécu on s'est tellement
fait d'effort bas attention attention
non c'est pas bien dur d'être arrêté
c'est vraiment ça en avant tout quoi
elle mais qu'elle a un franchement vous
n'avez pas un sujet à faire la main ces
biens furent ta propre km prendre que le
cas de m
pour patrick tu vas voir ça va faire mal
ça va faire mal à prendre ta gamelle way
[Musique]
ça
mais elle se sent pas du tout moi
doivent aller à mes jambes a pas manqué
après c'est le sens de mes poumons est
un conte la classe d un mec c'est
ignoble
ça existe allez vas-y refaisant les
mythes vas-y tu sais qu entre autres
direct prochaine fois que je m'en rende
compte bien attaquer le dit ça tu prends
pas d'eau mais mon geste
après moi je sais pas ça me fait un
choix si samnick tu vois mais ça fait du
bien aux [ __ ] ont découvert ma ale
près alors on attend jusqu'à maintenant
moi je vendais de l'eau sinon je mourrai
les à un mec jaloux de dessécher
s'affolent
bref c'est le caennais non halal ou pas
hoebeke du panu lazzarato avec tu parles
du val de cadel absolument des yeux
ignoble c'est ignoble
et encore c'est pas mon cas est nettoyé
je veux bien là dans la muette sur la
manette mondial robin écoute j'enlèverai
manet allait vite refait les clients
payent des taux non battant sèchement
fait tac tac tac tac vous dépeint âgées
à bord du monde parce que les ans un pas
des mensonges
[ __ ] les entends de nous voir j'ai
fait ce que je voulais dire nouveau en
train de cracher tu d'attaqué
les entendre nous wars la période n'est
pas un sujet à faire parler parler
parler d'un sujet à ces normes
nong
encore
lana avec la grand canal descendant mon
coeur mais ça puisque rationnelle à un
chaman à papa un sujet mais que ça me
pique les l'air d'accord le sujet partie
dans le seau
ça va mieux ah ouais ouais ouais je te
dis comme tout à l'heure que je suis
sceptique un peu sur sur black ops 2 au
moins nous les coudes innover orgasme et
ça donnera ea est encore une fois bas et
plus je vais en profiter encore comme
dans l'oeuvre dans beaucoup de vidéos je
veux vraiment toutes et tous vous
remercier pour ce superbe
c'est superbe cette superbe aventure que
vous fait vivre
ouais c'est sous classe et semble donc
on tient particulièrement à remercier
donc voici comment c'est moi quelque
chose de cool et on arrive de faire de
cette vidéo c'est quoi c'est quoi je
lance une grosse coeur pour finir on
fait de mailhac huillard et on essaie
d'aller au pied sans eau
ok ok ok bon ok ok ok voisine mais peu
mais toi pareil en fait tu as ta [ __ ]
vers la mecque j'en ai plus jamais
plusieurs fait plus atteint ce genre
mais non mais t'es quel genre menée dans
mais qu il allait ok mais que j'en ai
plus mais qu on s'en fout d'ailleurs là
on s'en fout sur un homme au laser à
mettre à cuire et était un gitan
allez allez prendre raquette est vrai à
les attentions dernière cuillère bien je
quitte la partie derniers temps je me
prends un peu d'eau un peu dans mon
verre tué parce que là ça va être la
cuillère de death attention serait de
l'eau bazire est prêt l essaimage anémie
léger pour l'essentiel et c'est pour
vous mais attends c'est tu prends pas
d'où tu essaies d'avaler achevé je vais
improviser
wen pour les cent mille je peux pas je
crois
tout ceci pour les 100000 âge au génial
attendant mesure cannelle paralysante
encore merci des drames engenio et on se
retrouve d'un côté comme une vidéo
encore plus afin de n'oublier pas
d'essai résider dans les commentaires
pour ce qu'il devra faire dans les
volets prochain défi n'oubliez pas
d'aller regarder précédent déficit
si vous ne connaissez pas et de laisser
un petit j'aime si vous avez aimé la
vidéo c'est quelque chose a rejeté mon
avis non au revoir à bientôt va adhérer
avait tué
[Musique]
alors